good morning um so uh jumping on in um i
always like to throw out a curveball as
my first question so for both of you if
you could get the financing to make
anything what would you make and why
um
if i could make anything right now i
mean the dream is always to work with
your friends right so i'd probably i'd
probably
take a chance to sing and dance again
i'd call i'd call my buddies
um
you know new york buddies i got some la
buddies out here you know some great
songwriters
and we'd make a big splashy musical why
not
um
yeah justin and benj are friends of mine
who you know won the oscar for la la
land so
let's do it
yeah i like that plan
john
i'm kind of with leslie you know to have
the financing to do the kinds of stories
that we all love
um to do things frankly like needle
where
working with leslie cynthia freda
orlando jaden and just making something
really beautiful and emotional and
bypoc individuals
as as people who love and regret and
um to me i loved it and i'm very
thankful to lionsgate you know you asked
that question fortunately
i didn't have to come up with my own
money and you have people like lionsgate
who support it and support this
beautiful film so
um i'm with leslie you know find beauty
in the space do the kinds of things you
want to do with the people who um you
feel really tight with and then just put
it out in the world and hope that people
appreciate the things that you do
uh this film the reason i get to talk to
you guys the the film has technology and
time travel but it's really not about
that as much as it's about love
and it's really it you know um i guess
for both of you what was it about this
script the story
that said um i want to do this
leslie
let me start you know it
for me just reading that story and for
everything you said it has science
fiction in it but it's not driven by
science fiction it's about love and
robert silverberg the author never tried
to explain either time travel or love
and they were just forces of nature
and for me you know as a young man when
i read the story in the
late 1990s i don't know if i was even
married yet i don't know if i had the
maturity to tell the kind of story but
years later um to be married to be with
a partner who's absolutely amazing to
have kids but to still look at your life
and wonder well what if and
if things were a little different would
i be here would it be the same would it
be different
um and to have a story at its source
that was just very mature in that
dispensation it wasn't
this thriller it wasn't a race to you
know close the portal and stop the
aliens
um it was really about adults trying to
find
meaning in their lives that's what i
appreciated about it and that's why i
stuck with it
in the you know the multiple decades
that it took to really bring this film
to
to where it is now which is you know in
theaters and streaming
listen
um i
really um i had a
lovely dinner
with john ridley with academy award
winner john ridley who i had met
we were like um
we didn't
see each other much but we had some
meaningful experiences on my very first
film redtails that john wrote
and this was really like us reconnecting
after all those years and and um i was
looking in his eyes and
you know he was
firstly which is the passion in john's
eyes and then i read his uh beautiful
script
and um
i was um
it was a very easy yes from me
one other thing i think about the fact
that one choice can just change your
life i think about it all the time that
the decisions we make and this film
talks about that how much do you guys
think about i guess uh and this is a
weird question i didn't really plan this
out but thinking about the fact that
like you know what i mean like in this
film talks about it that just you know
you deciding to go to la tomorrow or new
york could completely ripple your life
in an unexpected way and i i sort of
love the fact that this film talks about
that
yeah i think that um
you know without
i i try not to let that kind of um
that idea like paralyze me you know into
fear
um and raising kids too you want you
want them to
to be confident and bold in their
decision making and
to take risks
every now and again
but it's true yeah i think about it all
the time about like if i would have made
that left instead of right or if i would
have said yes to that instead of
instead of saying no you know my life
would be completely different
that is um
yeah
true
i had a hatred had a bit of that
experience making the film you know
originally the part that cynthia plays
was written for another actor somebody
had worked with before and
um really just have such a high regard
for and at the 11th hour her schedule
this other actor
was not going to work out
and i just felt like well there's
i can't make this film i'm never going
to find anybody who could replace that
other individual and in cynthia it
wasn't about replacing someone it's kind
of to your point there's another life
there's another version there's another
iteration of this story and
the chemistry that leslie and cynthia
have
um the quality of her performance the
quality of her just as a as a
professional partner and what she
brought
every day to work um
you know there's another film that in
another time and space maybe exists with
this other actor but
in this iteration it is
good it is beautiful it's its own thing
and that's sort of the magic about
life and about choices and about
happenstance
um it's not about right or wrong it's
not about good or bad it's about what
exists and
does what exists is it worthwhile and i
think the performance that
um leslie has with all of his
professional partners in this film is
extraordinary but certainly he and
cynthia together
are everything that you could have
wanted from a central couple
in a narrative like this it's compelling
it's complex the chemistry is off the
charts and
i'm just very fortunate to have worked
with these two amazing individuals
at that time in their lives and where
they are even in the the short two years
since we made the film
um it's just remarkable
yeah leslie can act i mean he's okay
he's all right if you need acting
dancing singing uh drama comedy yeah i
mean let's let's bring it down let's
bring it down let's not let's not get it
to
but i have to ask john another question
because i i'm fascinated by the editing
process because ultimately that's where
it all comes together i'm just curious
if you could talk about what you learned
when you got in the editing room and you
know how it possibly the film changed as
a result of you know how things go well
i have a really amazing editor lou that
i work with i work with back in american
crime and he's you know these
partnerships whether it's editing
whether it's wardrobe
dp
music you really want to work with
artisans and people that you have a
tight relationship with so that they
trust your intentionality going into it
but you trust things that they reveal on
the other side of it
and sifting through the performance is
things that on the set that you think
you have and you don't have or things
that are there and it wasn't necessarily
what your drive was on the day but it's
beautiful it's powerful it overwhelms
things in a really good way
so we think that it came together in all
those regards um again working with
leslie working with cynthia in
particular certainly frida i've worked
with in the past in orlando and jaden
um
there was just a level of chemistry in
all those spaces that it made us want to
bring moments to the fore there are
other scenes that you know didn't make
the cut but i don't think the film
suffers because they're not there
it's the totality of the scenes and you
look at them and go this is amazing this
is wonderful if we have to pick and
choose
this moment sells what we're trying to
arrive to in the story
and this one we thought it was great on
the day but i think we've got it and i
what i love about the film it doesn't
overstay it's welcome but it really
showcases the amazing talent that's in
front of the camera
uh leslie this is also a it's an
interesting role because you're
essentially you're playing multiple
versions of the same character and i'm
just curious what is it like and i don't
know how you filmed it but what i'm
assuming on some days you're playing
multiple versions on the same day can
you sort of talk about what it was like
as an actor portraying a role like this
yeah i really um i really leaned on john
who had such a um an understanding of of
this guy and also what he wanted to see
um so john is um
it was really a
like a you know a
you know
an intimate like you know friendship and
relationship that we had a discussion a
conversation that we had going the whole
time
um about that just making sure that i
was
emotionally where i needed to be
at all points in the in the picture so
uh yeah a lot of that came from my
discussion with with john
and um
and and the the confusion you know
i was able to
use it sometimes you know the the
confusion about you know trying to piece
together
um
my life and what's become of it
i was able to use in real time
that note i was going to say i need to
stop i'm just going to leave you guys
with i'm looking forward to knives out
too and a certain black panther comic
book i will just say it like
who's doing which
on that note i gotta go i'm listening
congrats thank you so much for talking
today with me thank you we appreciate it
thank you so much